let's face it school's not what it used
to be today's high schoolers are
learning how to fly drones and 3d
printing their artwork it's really cool
but also kind of scary
so what crazy new technologies will
replace number two pencils and good old
graph paper in the classrooms of the
future virtual reality has been around
since the 90s but now Facebook and
Google are no longer in your face
googles expeditions program turns
smartphones into virtual reality viewers
using simple inexpensive cardboard and
now that Facebook's bought oculus rift
they're planning on getting into
classroom gaming as early as next year
this is the first kind of headgear that
might get you into the popular crowd 3d
printing in schools is revolutionizing
the art of show-and-tell these printers
can make machine parts jewelry even guns
yesterday's arts and crafts is now
modern-day engineering elementary age
children are already using 3d printing
to design prosthetic hands remember how
you have to lug around heavy books and
then swap them out for other heavy books
from your locker well now there's the
cloud saving students from back problems
everywhere but the cloud could also give
teachers direct access to data on
student study habits by doing all their
homework online students provide
engagement data on how long they spent
on their assignments and whether or not
they're taking notes there's a bonus
though major publishers could use that
data to judge how effective and engaging
certain textbooks are so you could be
recycling that boring algebra books
with biometrics technology we've got
fingerprint scanning to borrow library
books and iris scanning instead of ID
cards teachers will even be able to tell
if you're concentrating or not during
online courses using eye-tracking
technology
yikes like old-school projectors but in
3d remember Michael Jackson's back from
the dead moonwalk performance
well hologram technology in classrooms
is still just a dream for now because
it's too expensive but in the future it
would allow teachers to give lessons to
students across the world imagine taking
a tour of a historic 3d model of the
Coliseum right from your desk the
potential for new technology in the
classroom is pretty amazing but will it
cause students who are plugged in all
the time to forget what it's like to
live in the real world